role models are definitely important for
the Middle East probably in particularly
I think women
a role model is successful professional
time when there are movements across the
region that believe the proper role for
woman is to be at home fact sometimes
only at home I think it's important that
aspiring
seeking career as well as family have
professional woman to look up to comenta
them
encourage them and
I think also there needs to be
people who are willing to encourage
critical thinking within education
within business within government the
region is going to progress you have you
have to have people in power to express
ideas that may not conform to the norm
in any of their of the institution but
for the progress of the entire week and
this is important